this is a very exciting moment for me my
life is all [ __ ] fires and issues so for
Tyler to say this is a good one
I'm excited amazing
what are you peeping two of the words in
there but it went well it was good so do
you want to focus on that that part of
my career like why I thought I was able
to go from being a wine retailer into
kind of this media thing I've become
when it comes to business I've always
been fearless
I didn't start swimming until I was nine
I was scared of dogs from pretty much my
whole life I don't like Heights all that
much I'm scared of like snakes like
things I'm not trying to tackle them I
have no interest in hanging around
snakes
I think everybody's got their strengths
and weaknesses when it comes to business
boy have I been fearless my whole life
sometimes people wait until their
parents die so they can run the business
you know I went a different route I
wanted to give back to my parents I
built the business for them and then I
check that box and took my skills
elsewhere I will say this I think the
surrounding neighborhoods of Manhattan
have a thing when you're in the heart of
it right the heart of the world I mean
New York City is literally literally
maybe arguably the most important city
in the world you know when you're within
miles of that you feel that heartbeat
but you're still not it right so you
have a little bit of that chip on your
shoulder there's a little bit of that
bridge and tunnels you know a little bit
of like you're the second tier of the
ultimate a tier and I you know I'll be
honest with you I think that is a
disproportionate advantage I think it's
a I think it's the most similar thing to
actually being an immigrant in America
you know it's having that little bit of
like hunger and chip and to end
and then when if you're lucky enough to
be an immigrant and grow up in Jersey I
think it's an edge
I think it's an intensity a vibe a comet
a level of common sense it's an
awareness but yeah I think it's a really
pretty special thing embrace the chip on
your shoulder and and and expand on it
and triple down on it and and really use
it to your advantage
awesome you're welcome take care bye bye
I have one play homework question that
I've been wondering would you say that
besides I guess family members it's been
in your biggest role model nobody nobody
that's the truth no one's ever really
inspired you do it I'm sure but I can't
figure it out the real answer trying to
figure out or something you just kind of
accepted like do you know who um you
know who like because they're not real
it's not like I've ever spent
any thoughtful time and saying which a
branson did this or I've just never done
that like kindness and compassion and
empathy and gratitude and good guys and
girls inspire me like oh that's a nice
person that's a good dude that gets me
going and then the market like everybody
like the game the game the market the
process but I've never really you know
my role models like me in 10 years
that's kind of that's interesting I kind
of that's interesting try to be yourself
in 10 years and when you get the offices
you're not that's that's cool
that that's a that's a better
articulation probably yeah that's I'm
very insular like really insular like
really like I don't even know about
people you know yeah
like the thought to take time to do
homework on somebody that I admire
it's like going outer space yeah but I
treat but notice it's a good microcosm
back to the thing you're right but I'm
agnostic yeah but I'm basically talking
to you as hard as I'd be talking to my
next meeting which is wladimir klitschko
yeah which is true literally wladimir
klitschko is walking in right now but
I'm not gonna try any harder it's just
the same yeah it's ended up being a
great attribute in hindsight I think
people sing me I think people
subconsciously feel it
I think big big name people realize I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah and I think
people on the coming up appreciate it
yeah yeah it's a weird entire life it's
a competitive advantage it's a
competitive advantage you know the thing
for me is like I'm just like don't care
I'm just in I do the right thing at the
right moment every time I just yeah cuz
I don't think anybody's gonna do
anything for me yeah I don't observe
expectations and I can get everything by
myself
did you always think that yeah don't
forget II think I had a lot of
advantages I was a bad student I didn't
grow up in a big time family so I had a
lot of advantages because I didn't know
the alternative yes sure I didn't know
what if the Hamptons were I didn't even
know what oh you go to an Ivy League
school or a good school or [ __ ] if I
knew that [ __ ] I should at least in a
little bit just for mission if it was
Michigan Wisconsin Indiana right I
would've been like oh look I didn't even
know that meant anything I was in such
an immigrant insular cocoon in my own
head in my own little family I didn't
even do like extracurricular activities
it was just insular it was super weird
the last ten years I'm like oh that's
why it's good to go to Penn you know
because your roommate might be [ __ ] it
you know yeah like I didn't know that's
given me an unbelievable advantage
[Music]
rumors are that there was no music why
would you not use the airport Gary music
when I'm turning into an airport Gary
[Music]